my brothers and sisters the first
church's comic books I come to you today
to bear witness to the glory of the
spider-mans yes I am
can I get a name man can I get a name
for today we have looked on looked upon
the civil war trailer and we have seen
that Marvel is finally brought
spider-man to us just the half yes they
have my brothers and sisters yes think
it's time for celebration there's a time
for for rejoice can I get a name
I have no idea where I'm going with this
I have long since awaited
despite a man to debut in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and since we first
saw that news article saying that Sony
made the right decision and admitted
that they didn't know how to make a
spider-man movie even though all the
spider-man movies to date show they
don't know how to make a spider-man
movie Sony finally said we don't know
what we're doing here you go marvel
you're the one that made him you're the
one that brought him into the comic book
industry you're the reason why he's
popular it's because of people like you
that made spider-man so great they were
fine I'm they're gonna go ahead and give
him back to you so you can put him in
Marvel's Civil War movie probably the
best Marvel movie that's gonna be coming
out anytime soon and he'll infinity war
can I get an amen we are finally gonna
see him in this movie yes we are my
brothers and sisters yes we are yes I
know some people in the comments for the
Civil War movie are saying his eyes are
animated they don't like his suit
because it's got not just blue and red
but it's got a little bit of black in it
now I know they're not being racial or
anything like that I know that because I
am a reasonable human being I just think
those people look goofy because at the
end of the day my brothers and sisters
who cares what his suit groups like
there is a guy named Peter Parker who
was bitten by a radioactive spider who
can shoot wedding maybe from his body
maybe is from Webb sure is I don't know
and I don't care
he's wearing a spider-man suit yes he is
can I get an amen
and he's gonna be in Civil War can I get
an amen yes sir
yes sir
our father
Kevin Feige who art in Hollywood assume
he's in Hollywood I don't know he's
actually Hollywood or not who art in
Hollywood
hallowed be thy name
we look to you to ensure that the gift
that you've bestowed upon us in the form
of spider-man shall not go to waste no
it shall not can I get a name in that it
will be treated well that you'll do a
much better job than someone did which
ain't that hard to do but you'll do a
much better job and so they didn't you
will give us you'll give us a spider-man
that is worthy of the collared book eret
assuming that we ignore one more day we
get a spider-man that is worthy of the
legacy that we are so familiar with and
we pray to you Kevin Feige that one day
it doesn't have to be today it doesn't
have to be tomorrow it doesn't have to
be next year it could even be in 2020
that one day one day one day yeah we
give Miles Morales yes ah the ultimate
spider-man yes
my brothers and sisters let us bask in
this moment let us look upon this
trailer with eyes of wonder and bear
witness to the greatness that is the
Marvel Cinematic Universe yes let us
acknowledge the fact that unlike those
today the test then in like eight days
we're not gonna see the Punisher let us
pray
that in this movie let us pray that in
this movie much like how it took place
in the comic books one of the greatest
moments in civil war yes it was can I
get an amen
yes it was can I get an amen that we
will see a fight between Captain America
and spider-man because I don't know
about you my brothers and sisters of the
comic book world I don't know about you
but I believe yes I do I believe we can
I get a name and I'm asking for a lot of
eight minutes can I get a name man yes I
believe that a fight between Captain
America and spider-man would be
something to behold yes it would we
would walk out of that theater and we
would say my goodness gracious did you
see that fight between the two and I
would say yes I have I have bear witness
to the glory of the spider
my brothers and sisters though there are
many things that separate us
sometimes it's the distance between us
because you know we live in different
countries and stuff but sometimes there
are things that bind us that bring us
together that give us this moment
together yes uh can I get a name in one
of these things is our love of watching
a man dressed as a spider fighting
another man dresses the American flag
holding a shield but nothing can
penetrate except for adamantium which we
won't see because Marvel so stupidly
sold the rights of the x-men to Fox so
they can make movies and screw them up
except for Days of Future past because
that was good I have no idea what I was
gonna say Nick oh yes I know what I was
gonna say next what I was gonna say next
was this moment brings us together comic
book lovers yes it does it brings us
together as fans of comic book movies it
reminds us why it was that DC so
intelligently decided not to release
Batman vs Superman on the same weekend
as Captain America Civil War because I
do like Batman vs Superman the movie
will be good but I think Civil War will
be better yes it will can I get a name
man can I get an amen
as we bring this sermon to a close on
the helicopter passes by blackness I
wish they wouldn't do that let us let us
come together in praying
value
as we look up home the splatter be we
ask one thing
that the actor who was playing like him
amazing
that he does a good job that he does
extremely well in that role so that
after the first spider-man movie comes
out next year that he will continue to
see more of Peter Parker and eventually
we will see the spider-man franchise in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe elevate to
such a degree that we will see Miles
Morales show up because Marvel will say
there's so much love for spider-man
right now we need spotted win we need
Miles Morales we need Peter Orca we need
all these different versions of
spider-man from across the multiverse
coming into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so that they may they may bring
us all these different versions we can
see uncle being spider-man we don't need
to see the inheritance because they were
stupid but we can see all the stuff
that's good from the spider universe and
we can come together and say yes this is
why we love spider-man because he's
amazing
without being said my brothers and
sisters we're gonna wrap this sermon up
yes we are well going to end of this
sermon and we're going to continue to
give praise to the spider
we'll continue to give praise to Kevin
Feige we'll continue to give praise to
the model Cinematic Universe so that
they may one day do other cool stuff
with movies I have no idea attendance
but with that being said my brothers and
sisters we're gonna bring this to me yes
we are can I get an Amy and I will catch
you all later peace